with lane sling there's a chance this
will be his final start in a rangers
uniform if it is what a pickup he's been
for them in the second year of a
three-year contract last year in his
eighth major league season he had his
best season yet he got cy young votes
and he's been even better this year
that's lead off man aboard in the form
of bets and up comes corey seeger
they're shooting it again and seeger
goes after it for the strikeout two out
for bellinger here in the first when it
goes a 3-2 a swing and a miss and a
strikeout of bellinger ends the innings
ross
his seventh start three and one a 546
era most troublesome number is that in
29 and two-thirds innings he has given
up 10
home runs
here's todd frazier ninth pitch
got him to chase
and into one two three first for ross
strickland one out matt baby coming up
the ground ball up the middle at the
center field for a base hit matt baby is
a board with a one out single to center
pollock rips it down the line it'll roll
all the way to the left field corner
beatty on his horse headed for third as
true has trouble picking it up baby's
gonna come for the plate and score
dodgers strike first here in the second
on an extra base hit from aj [ __ ] for
the dodgers with the game's first run
and a double from aj pollock and he's in
scoring position for gavin lux
he takes strike three and there are two
gone in the inning it's counter for left
two for four yesterday is average up to
270 right-handed batter
bouncing ball left side seeger lux
double play good dig from baby here's
chloe seeger who stands it on the left
side playoff pitch and a swing and a
miss picks up his fifth strike out of
the night muncie flies to center his
first time be interesting to see here we
saw him wince and hold his left forearm
on a check swing his first at-bat
muncie cranks the base hit to right that
one will scoot all the way to the corner
where gallow picks it up twirls and
throws muncie is in with a double
so it gives bellinger an opportunity
here dodgers coming off a game where
they were two for 12 with runners in
scoring position uh second two gun and
another three two from lance lynn
bellinger hits a high fly ball to right
field gallows back he's at the wall
there it goes home run cody bellinger
a two-run shot against lancelin makes it
three-nothing dodgers right out of
lancelin's hands max muncie could see
that was going to be a strike and take
an aggressive lead but after the
aggressive lead he didn't have to run he
just got to trot around the bases when
you watch the flight of the ball
here it's a strike the whole way get off
the base and then cody says you don't
have to worry about running so this
rangers offense tonight is going to have
to come from behind to get it done
guzman first pitch swinging that ball
pounded deep to center gone
and guzman
watches one on the first pitch of the
inning it's a 3-1 ball game where you
been ronald ronald said i missed being
here and i want to stay here
and i got something to show you
it's going to take more than that but
hopefully that's a start so guzman
lights up the scoreboard now leyote
tavares
and he hits one hard out to left center
field long run out there that one's gone
back to back home runs
guzman
and tavares his first in his big league
career and it's a 3-2 game that shows
some power by the 21 year old two
pitches two runs lead off walk austin
barnes back to the top mookie bets
wow that is blistered down the line into
the left field corner barnes can really
run evil going to give this a read and
stop him at third with nobody out on a
double from bats and muncie coming up
having doubled his last time
muncie hits a fly ball right center
field sending gattle back he's on the
track he's at the wall and he makes the
catch right up against the top of the
wall barnes in to score to make it 4-2
but muncie missed by that much
so blake kreinen now on in relief for
the dodger and he inherits first and
second nobody out in the bottom of the
fifth two left-handed hitters
two on the next pitch
goes to medium deep left field pollock
underneath it
trying to score he will the sac fly
makes it a one-run game
two on one out seventh inning
is trying to add on a little too close
for comfort here now it's muncie
that ball is drilled in the air to right
back goes gallow running out of room
it's gone
muncie with a three-run shot to break it
open the dodgers seven the rangers three
hoping to get two with second and third
and one out max muncie assures him of
the two
and makes the third one himself
bottom of the ninth inning a 7-4 lead
for the dodgers and here's kenley
janssen
tavares coming up strike three it's a
good comeback from the walk one on one
out for shinto
he struck him out finally in the tent
pitch you get shinsu and the rangers
down to their last out
reaches out slaps it on the ground to
second there's lux
there's the game and the dodgers have
even the series at a game of peace they
again set themselves up
for a chance at another series win
tomorrow